sprechen wir über diese kriegssituation
mit alexander graf lambsdorff dem
außenpolitischen experten der fdp und
europapolitiker lambsdorff
blut sie ich grüße sie auch in west nahe
paris hat sich die eu haben sich die
staats und regierungschefs getroffen
heute und haben noch mal die hilfe für
militärische güter für die ukraine
aufgestockte noch einmal 500 millionen
wir sehen das bild sie sitzen dort im
prunksaal invest zusammen
bemerkungen nebenbei unser reporter paul
ronzheimer der seite wochen in kiew aus
tat sagt das sei das falsche signal
dieser prunksaal dieses spiegel weil
dort das würde von den menschen in der
ukraine falsch verstanden werden können
aber nichtsdestotrotz es geht um geld es
geht um militärische hilfe die die
ukraine dringend braucht ist das der
richtige schritt reicht das
ja dazu zwei antworten paul ronzheimer
hat natürlich recht aus der ukraine
betrachtet muss das merkwürdig wirken
aber vergessen wir bitte eines nicht in
vier wochen wird in frankreich der
präsident gewählt und emanuel makro
braucht solche bilder wo er sozusagen
als chef der europäischen union gerade
als ratspräsident die anderen staats und
regierungschefs in den prachtvollsten
saal von frankreich erholt und dort
vorsitzt das hebt seine chancen und
deswegen aus französischer sicht ist
dieses bild mehr als verständlich es
gibt eben verschiedene logischen zu
gleicher zeit am werk sind wichtig ist
ja das was dabei herauskommt was da
entschieden wird und da glaube ich wäre
auch paul ronzheimer zufrieden da können
auch die menschen in der ukraine mit
zufrieden sein klares bekenntnis der
europäischen union zur unterstützung für
die ukraine klares bekenntnis dazu mehr
tun zu wollen auch das stelle ich
zunehmend fest der wunsch der ob
militärisch zu helfen wo wir uns auch
nicht unbedingt sofort im internet
postet früher hätte man gesagt an die
litfaßsäule schlägt die franzosen selber
haben ja schon erklärt sie helfen aber
sie sagen nicht und ich glaube das wird
in der zukunft noch stärker so sein dass
man den ukrainern diskret hilft
entschlossen hilft mit viel geld hilft
aber nicht mehr jeden tag darüber redet
was es genau ist womit man hilft
diskret helfen sagen sie der ukrainische
botschafter in deutschland herr mendig
der großen applaus bekommen hat im
bundestag standing ovations hatte jetzt
weitere waffen gefordert und zwar auch
schwere waffen auch panzer und flugzeuge
er hat gesagt der westen sei feige wenn
er das nicht tut und auch deutschland
sei feige
ich kenne andrej melik natürlich gut wir
arbeiten zusammen wir haben uns auch
schon vor dem krieg häufig getroffen ich
finde er hat eine sehr deutliche sprache
die für einen diplomaten manchmal
vielleicht sogar etwas zu deutlich ist
ich glaube dass er und seine landsleute
zufrieden sein können mit dem was wir
leisten wir sehen ja auch dass der
heldenhafte kampf der ukrainischen
streitkräfte
unterstützt wird durch die waffen und
beides zusammen ergibt ja einen
stop fast schon ein stopp ist
übertrieben aber eine verzögerung würde
man militärisch sagen eine verzögerung
des russischen vormarsch von wirklich
signifikantem ausmaß also mannschaft der
magic ist ist natürlich aufgewühlt und
will alles was geht ich verstehe dass
angesichts der lage in seinem land
deutschland hat vor zehn tagen eine
sicherheitspolitische zeitenwende
eingeleitet wir sind mit dabei wenn die
europäer unterstützen ich glaube die
zusammenarbeit ist gut
es ist ein ehemaliger deutscher
bundeskanzler in geheimer mission
sozusagen nach moskau gereist ohne auch
die bundesregierung offenbar zu
informieren und die eigene partei auch
nicht
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wie altkanzler
gerhard schröder beide in der spd mann
hätte sich vorstellen können dass man da
ein kurzes zeichen gibt und sagt hallo
ich war über zu meinem alten freund
putin wir sehen wir noch mal bilder und
was erwarten sie von dieser situation
graf lambsdorff würde ich sie gleich
sofort noch einmal fragen denn in dieser
sekunde hören wir dass der ukrainische
präsident sinn lenski eine rede hält da
können wir vielleicht gemeinsam einmal
kurz reinhören hier sehe
ich
da kein problem ist
wo die
katastrophe
ich weiß nicht wie ihr ukrainisch ist
der mainz ist nicht so gut als dass ich
da hätte verstehen können außer
katastrophe und dem bombardement aber
dass es im prinzip das was ja auch alles
ausdrückt ja was er gesagt hat ich
spreche kein ukrainisch aber ein
bisschen russisch und was sie lenski
gesagt ist sagt in mehreren obersten
gibt es jetzt wieder gas wasser noch
strom und benutzen dafür das wort der
humanitären katastrophe aber diese zwei
worte humanitäre katastrophe verbergen
eigentlich das worum es wirklich geht
und das ist dass das ganze ausgeht von
der russischen föderation dass wir es
mit einem angriffskrieg zu tun haben
dass die belagerung von mario pohl
weiter geht und dieses russische handeln
diese katastrophe noch weiter verstärken
verschärft also er beschreibt die lage
so wie sie ist graf lambsdorff unser
künftiger dolmetscher jederzeit
herzlichen dank herr stichwort
dolmetscher noch mal führt uns nochmal
zu erklärt röder der dort auch als
dolmetscher jetzt fragen auftreten will
was halten sie davon grundsätzlich gut
jeden versuch zu unternehmen oder doch
irgendwie merkwürdig so was in so einer
geheimen mission zu machen
gibt es
eigentlich nur sich selbst
dann auch durchdringt ist das andere ich
bin da sehr skeptisch dass wladimir
putin sich jetzt von gerd schröder davon
abhalte
halten lässt zu tun was er in der
ukraine tut insofern eine merkwürdige
aktion man kann immer auf wunder hoffen
also tun wir das mal an dieser stelle
aber
mehr als eine hoffnung auch wenn und
kann das nicht sein wir hatten hatte
sich gerade noch eine stimme dazu
geschlichen deshalb die irritation
noch mal die frage sie sind langjähriger
politiker entspricht es den
gepflogenheiten dann die bundesregierung
zumindest das muss ja nicht die ganze
partei sein wenn man in einer sozusagen
heiklen geheimen nenne sie mal missionen
unterwegs ist aber doch zumindest dem
deutschen bundeskanzler davon zu
unterrichten der ja eben auch noch ein
parteifreund ist dass man da unterwegs
ist ja auch über istanbul und damit
einer russischen maschine abgeholt wird
alles wie in einem halben agenten krimi
ja gut also über ist der mur kann man
ihm nicht vorwerfen die lufträume sind
gegenseitig gesperrt aber sie sprechen
den richtigen punkt an hier reißt ein
ehemaliger bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland der von der
bundesrepublik deutschland einen
ehrensold für seine vergangenen
tätigkeiten erhält der auch nur
unterstützung erhält durch ein grund
durch mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
der also mit anderen worten nach wie vor
unterstützung dafür erhält das er im
dienst der bundesrepublik deutschland
seine tätigkeit als ehemaliger
bundeskanzler ausübt dass in einer
solchen lage dann die bundesregierung
nicht über diesen besuch informiert geht
gar nicht um es ganz klar zu sagen das
geht überhaupt nicht er müssen sie sich
dann entscheiden wirklich konsequent den
schnitt zu machen und auch auf die
zuwendungen der bundesrepublik
deutschland zu verzichten dann könnte
man sagen er ist wirklich als privatmann
unterwegs
vielleicht hat es auch angestellter der
konzerne die von wladimir putin
kontrolliert werden aber in dieser
situation ohne unterrichtung der
bundesregierung zu fahren das geht gar
nicht der fdp-außenexperte alexander
graf lambsdorff danke für das gespräch
und danke nochmal für die spontane
simultanübersetzung ganz herzlich
wahrscheinlich nicht besonders gut aber
ich hoffe sie kommt der sache
einigermaßen hat uns sehr geholfen
vielen dank